let's take you live to that space race
Center correspondent Dan Whitehead joins
us from near the takeoff site Dan tell
us what it feels like there it must be
pretty exciting tonight for this first
ever space launch from Cornwall
really is a big moment I remember coming
down to Newquay airport four years ago
when this news was first announced and
now we are already around three and a
half hours away from the Rocket taking
off so this is how it's going to work
right next to me here is a prototype a
replica of launcher one which Thomas was
explaining about there this is what's
going to carry those satellites up under
the wing on the 747 a former Virgin
Atlantic plane which is around a
kilometer down the runway there it is
getting primed it is getting ready for
the launch it gets to 35 000 feet then
this rocket is ignited 17 and a half
thousand miles per hour taking those
satellites into orbit and they're around
2 000 people who have come down here to
witness this spectacle including the
mcness family who've come and not too
far from bodmin uh here and you've got
all your gear you've got your camping
chairs ready
how are you feeling this is this is
exciting stuff it is exciting yes we're
all ready you've got lots of layers on
waiting for history in the making look
there are only 2 000 tickets and I think
they it crashed away website earlier
this week a lot of people didn't get
tickets what made you and the family
once want to come down here we've been
following it what's going on and
I went on to look and we managed to get
our tickets and here we are excited and
it's George Oliver and piran I think who
the kids were where's George hello
George how old are you
how excited are you about tonight really
excited what are you most looking
forward to seeing the plane the plane as
it takes on yes and it's Oliver Oliver I
know that you've been looking forward to
coming down here all day that moment
we've got a big screen set up as well of
course because when this rocket is
detached it's going to be 35 000 feet up
in the air how are you gonna feel once
you see that rocket ignite and go into
space I'm really really excited it's
like once in a lifetime experience isn't
it to see this so first time in the UK
as well so it's really exciting yeah I
can't really know how are you feeling
today yeah it's really exciting like
never seen anything like this before
I've never even been in an airport
before let alone see a rocket like yeah
and the plane's so huge I saw it earlier
yeah it's amazing yeah you've got your
chairs have you got enough layers are
you all wearing enough it's gonna get
cold tonight yeah like five five layers
plenty of snacks as well
I'll let you go and get a good spot
because as I say there are a couple of
thousand people thanking them in a big
nice family who are coming down tonight
they got their tickets and as well as
members of the public this is the VIP 10
which is starting to fill up tonight
lots of people of course have been
invested in this and have been looking
forward to this and I put a lot of work
into this over the last four or five
years this is the UK's first orbital
rocket launch from UK soil and virgin
orbit has chosen Cornwall for this
Mission nine satellites on board and
they all being well will be orbiting
space in the we hours of this morning
Dan thanks very much indeed for now